situation est largement décrite décrite
par ailleurs donc effectivement c'est
comme dire que c'est simple au niveau
des hôpitaux de france classée et ça
serait vous raconter n'importe quoi
les équipes sont sous tension donc voilà
le message qu'il faut je pense continuer
à faire passer les marques connaissent
effectivement qu'il faut que tout le
monde reste bien qu'elle soit pourquoi
l'attention de façon à éviter les
contaminations parce que ce dont on peut
se rendre compte c'est que les
contaminations vont très vite donc il
faut vraiment être extrêmement prudent
dans son comportement est adoptée tous
les gestes barrière de parce qu'on se
protéger soi même mais également
protéger les autres c'est important ça
marche dans les deux sens vraiment avoir
une notion de se protéger mais quand on
se protège en protège également les
zones donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'essentiel à retenir quoi et plus
les gens se protégeront qui est moins la
pression sur le système hospitalier
traqueront et ça aussi c'est important
puisqu'on sait très bien que moins de
gens vont se retrouver à l'hôpital et
plus dont pourra prendre les gens en
charge de façon convenable et sans
aucune difficulté
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir note surtout
se protéger pour ne pas finir à la fois
les mesures du gouvernement c'est de
placer la france en confinement ça s'est
épris s'il mesure qui est à la hauteur
en tout cas pour pour lutter
efficacement contre la propagation du
virus restait est une mesure c'est une
mesure indispensable inédite
je pense que personne en france
l'imaginer ça il ya encore trois
semaines ou un mois
mais c'est une mesure qui est à la
hauteur des enjeux aujourd'hui parce
qu'on auront seconde contre ans qu'on
sait qu'on n'est pays
ils sont pas et qui n'ont pas pris ses
précautions là aujourd'hui son temps
sont en difficulté alors je parle pas de
l'italie et de l'espagne seront pas que
l'on des mesures mais qui
malheureusement en efficacité d'un tête
pas été au rendez vous on est peut-être
à chercher pour 20 jours mais là il
suggère une ethnie qui ont retardé à
prendre des mesures d'angleterre par
exemple vont avoir à faire face à des
avants à la une a une incidence bien
largement supérieure à celle qu'on a
rencontré des états unis où ses
confrères de démarrer en flèche
également je pense que ces mesures
étaient absolument indispensable ne pas
les prendre et est suicidaire on l'a
compris un puro aussi aider le personnel
soignant qui est totalement
engagé dans cette crise le personnel
soignant qui est aussi un besoin de deux
renforts il ya les étudiants en médecine
notamment qui viennent en aide à ce
personnel soignant est ce que des
étudiants de l'ub est ce que je rappelle
que vous êtes vice doyen de l'ufr de
santé des sciences de la santé de l'ue
est ce qu est ce que des étudiants de
l'uvsq prêtent main forte au personnel
soignant principalement des étudiants
prêtent main forte au personnel soignant
bien évidemment ce tronçon de deux
futurs professionnels de santé donc
c'est tout à fait normal puisque qu'ils
puissent participer à cet effort
il ya différentes façons de le faire
effectivement il ya dans les services
non très directement imaginé il ya
d'autres il ya d'autres solutions qui
existent et notamment la mobilité d'un
certain nombre des leurs mais signe sur
une nouvelle plate-forme de réponse
téléphonique a été mise en place par
l'ap-hp l'assistance des hôpitaux de
paris
et c'est pour éviter justement la
surcharge hospitalière la surcharge des
médecins libéraux répond enregistré car
fellini services d'urgence quand il voit
passer aucun train qui est susceptible
d'être d'être positif et il est et qui
présente la symptomatologie du coc vide
ces gens sont inclus sur sur une plate
sur une application le médecin et
rentrer sur l'application et ensuite ils
sont suivis à distance via cette
application pas d'été des consultants
qui sont donc qui peuvent être des
étudiants des infirmières est organisée
en cellules et chaque cellule est
supervisé par un médecin donc c'est on
évite à travers ce système là déjà
anglais que les gens à la maison ça
évite de surcharger les hôpitaux
david me suis chargé des portions de
deux médecins généralistes a dit aux
gens de sortir et d'aller voir des aides
à l'arrêt et de croiser les gens me font
passer dans d'aller dans des salles
d'accord vient donc de limiter les
contacts et donc éviter les
contaminations
ça c'est extrêmement important et
surtout un point essentiel c'est céline
ça rassure ça rassure énormément les
patients de se savoir surveiller à
distance il remplit seul un petit
questionnaire deux fois par jour sur une
application et un petit les niveaux
d'alerté en france ni colère on rappelle
d'agents les gens qui m'ont bien il n'y
a pas de raison dérapé en revanche les
gens qui présentent une altération de
leur santé oms les rappels ont fait le
point avec eux et s'il faut on appelle
le samu ou indirectement qu'on a la
chance
il a privilégié avec les différences à
motifs de plantes et bien merci le
exaucera nous avoir accordé quelques
minutes
et bon courage à vous merci au revoir je
voulais juste rajouter que oui elle est
effectivement le personnel soignant on
en parle beaucoup mais il ya beaucoup de
gens travaillent à l'hôpital il n'y a
pas que du personnel assurément donc ça
faut pas l'oublier et il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens en dehors de l'hôpital
qui travaillent qui continuent à
travailler ils permettent aussi aux
personnels soignants de continuer la
tournée c'est aussi important
à les voir en tête tout le monde est
important à condition de bien respecter
les mesures barrières et bien merci
d'avoir répondu aux questions télé 78
merci nous ont pris